learning German is back in fashion
especially in developing countries like
India issuers I want to work as an
engineer in germany deutschland many
learn the language to find a job or to
study at a german university to Lexi
omnia besandose we've made gains in
places with emerging middle class China
Asia Latin America latina Europe has
remained more or less stable we note
that German is also coming back in the
former Soviet republics in londonderry
mailings of the country where German is
most popular is Poland with 2.3 million
people learning the language is poor in
advance Michael Maybury media one
mention and this is how it looks
worldwide in France just ten percent of
school students choose German as a
foreign language and there are concerns
that new educational reforms may push
the number down even further das buddha
untoward that would mean not only a
major drop in the ability to speak
German but also in the understanding
between Germany and France it could be a
turning point for the franco-german
friendship hunters ship horn chef but it
may not be the last word on the matter
as the reforms face some opposition from
the French the two countries are
important trade partners and the German
language could be key to creating more
jobs in France